hey vsauce michael here there's a famous
way to seemingly create chocolate out of
nothing maybe you've seen it before this
chocolate bar is four squares by eight
squares but if you cut it like this and
then like this and finally like this you
can rearrange the pieces like so and
wind up with the same four by eight bar
but with a leftover piece apparently
created out of thin air
there's a popular animation of this
illusion as well
i call it an illusion because it's just
that
fake in reality the final bar is a bit
smaller it contains
this much less chocolate each square
along the cut is shorter than it was in
the original but the cut makes it
difficult to notice right away the
animation is extra misleading because it
tries to cover up its deception the lost
height of each square is surreptitiously
added in while the piece moves to make
it hard to notice
i mean come on obviously you cannot cut
up a chocolate bar and rearrange the
pieces into more than you started with
or can you
one of the strangest theorems in modern
mathematics is the banach tarsky paradox
it proves that there is in fact a way to
take an object
and
separate it into five different pieces
[Music]
and then with those five pieces simply
rearrange them no stretching required
into
two exact copies of the original item
same density same size same everything
seriously to dive into the mind blow
that it is and the way it fundamentally
questions math and ourselves we have to
start by asking a few questions
first what is
infinity
a number
i mean it's nowhere on the number line
but we often say things like there's an
infinite number of
blah blah and as far as we know infinity
could be real the universe may be
infinite in size and flat extending out
forever and ever without end beyond even
the part we can't observe or ever hope
to observe
that's exactly what infinity is
not a number per se but rather a size
the size of something that doesn't end
infinity is not the biggest number
instead it is how many numbers there are
but there are different sizes of
infinity
the smallest type of infinity is
countable infinity the number of hours
in forever it's also the number of whole
numbers that there are natural numbers
the numbers we use when counting things
like 1 2 3 4 5 6 and so on
sets like these are unending but they
are
countable
countable means that you can count them
from one element to any other in a
finite amount of time
even if that finite amount of time is
longer than you will live or the
universe will exist for it's still
finite
uncountable infinity on the other hand
is literally
bigger
too big to even count the number of real
numbers that there are not just whole
numbers but all numbers is uncountably
infinite you literally cannot count even
from zero to one in a finite amount of
time by naming every real number in
between
i mean
where do you even start
zero okay but
what comes next
0.0000
eventually we would imagine a one going
somewhere at the end but there is no end
we could always add another zero
uncountability makes this set so much
larger than the set of all whole numbers
that even between 0 and 1 there are more
numbers than there are whole numbers on
the entire endless number line
derrick cantor's famous diagonal
argument helps illustrate this imagine
listing every number between 0 and 1.
since they are uncountable and can't be
listed in order let's imagine randomly
generating them forever with no repeats
each number we generate can be paired
with a whole number if there's a
one-to-one correspondence between the
two that is if we can match one whole
number to each real number on our list
that would mean that countable and
uncountable sets are the same size but
we can't do that
even though this list goes on forever
forever isn't enough
watch this if we go diagonally down our
endless list of real numbers and take
the first decimal of the first number
and the second of the second number the
third of the third and so on and add one
to each subtracting one if it happens to
be a nine we can generate a new real
number that is obviously between 0 and 1
but since we've defined it to be
different from every number on our
endless list and at least one place it's
clearly not contained in the list
in other words we've used up every
single whole number the entire infinity
of them and yet we can still come up
with more
real numbers
here's something else that is true but
counter-intuitive
there are the same number of even
numbers as there are even and odd
numbers
at first that sounds ridiculous clearly
there are only half as many even numbers
as all whole numbers
but that intuition is wrong the set of
all whole numbers is denser but every
even number can be matched with a whole
number you will never run out of members
of either set so this one-to-one
correspondence shows that both sets are
the same size
in other words infinity divided by two
is still infinity
infinity plus one is also infinity a
good illustration of this is hilbert's
paradox of the grand hotel
imagine a hotel with a countably
infinite number of rooms but now imagine
that there is a person booked into every
single room seemingly it's fully booked
right
no
infinite sets go against common sense
you see if a new guest shows up and
wants a room all the hotel has to do is
move the guest in room number one to
room number two and the guest in room
two to room three and three to four and
four to five and so on because the
number of rooms is never ending we
cannot run out of rooms
infinity minus one is also
infinity again if one guest leaves the
hotel we can shift every guest the other
way guest two goes to room one three to
two four to three and so on because we
have an infinite amount of guests that
is a never-ending supply of them no room
will be left empty
as it turns out you can subtract any
finite number from infinity and still be
left with infinity it doesn't care it's
unending
tarsky hasn't left our sights yet all of
this is related we are now ready to move
on to shapes hilbert's hotel can be
applied to a circle
points around the circumference can be
thought of as guests if we remove one
point from the circle that point is gone
right
infinity tells us it doesn't matter the
circumference of a circle is irrational
it's the radius times two pi so if we
mark off points beginning from the hole
every radius length along the
circumference going clockwise we will
never land on the same point twice
ever
we can count off each point we mark with
a whole number so this set is never
ending but countable just like guests in
rooms in hilbert's hotel and like those
guests even though one has checked out
we can just shift the rest
move them
counter-clockwise and every room will be
filled
point one moves to fill in the hole
point two fills in the place where point
one used to be three fills in two and so
on
since we have an unending supply of
numbered points no hole will be left
unfilled
the missing point
is forgotten we apparently never needed
it to be complete
there's one last nido consequence of
infinity we should discuss before
tackling bonoktarsky
ian stewart famously proposed a
brilliant dictionary
one that he called the hyperwebster the
hyperwebster lists every single possible
word of any length formed from the 26
letters in the english alphabet it
begins with a
followed by a a then aaa then aaa and
after an infinite number of those a b
then a b a then a b a a a b a a a and so
on until z
z-a z-a-a etc etc until the final entry
an infinite sequence of z's
such a dictionary would contain every
single word nay every single thought
definition description truth lie name
story what happened to amelia earhart
would be in that dictionary
as well as every single thing that
didn't happen to amelia earhart
everything that could be said using our
alphabet
obviously
it would be huge but the company
publishing it might realize that they
could take a shortcut
if they put all the words that begin
with a in a volume titled a
they wouldn't have to print the initial
a readers would know to just add the a
because it's the a volume by removing
the initial a the publisher is left with
every a word sans the first a which has
surprisingly become every possible word
just one of the 26 volumes has been
decomposed into the entire
thing it is now that we're ready to
investigate this video's titular paradox
what if we turned an object a 3d thing
into a hyper webster could we decompose
pieces of it
into the whole thing
yes
the first thing we need to do is give
every single point on the surface of the
sphere one name and one name only a good
way to do this is to name them after how
they can be reached by a given starting
point if we move this starting point
across the surface of the sphere in
steps that are just the right length no
matter how many times or in what
direction we rotate so long as we never
backtrack it will never wind up in the
same place twice
we only need to rotate in four
directions to achieve this paradox up
down left and right around two
perpendicular axes we are going to need
every single possible sequence that can
be made of any finite length out of just
these four rotations that means we will
need left
right up and down as well as
left left left up left down but of
course not left right because well
that's backtracking going left and then
right means you're the same as you were
before you did anything so no left
rights no right lefts and no up downs
and no down ups also notice that i'm
writing the rotations in order right to
left so the final rotation is the
leftmost letter that will be important
later on anyway a list of all possible
sequences of allowed rotations that are
finite in length
is
well huge
countably infinite in fact but if we
apply each one of them to a starting
point in green here and then name the
point we land on after the sequence that
brought us there we can name a countably
infinite set of points on the surface
let's look at how say these four strings
on our list would work
right up left okay rotating the starting
point this way takes us
here
let's color code the point based on the
final rotation in its string in this
case it's left and for that we will use
purple
next up down down
that sequence takes us here we name the
point dd and color it blue since we
ended with a down rotation
rdr that will be this point's name takes
us here and for a final write rotation
let's use red
finally for a sequence that ends with up
let's color code the point orange now if
we imagine completing this process for
every single sequence we will have a
countably infinite number of points
named and color coded that's great
but not enough
there are an uncountably infinite number
of points on a sphere's
surface but no worries we can just pick
a point we missed any point and color it
green making it a new starting point and
then run every sequence from here
after doing this to an uncountably
infinite number of starting points we
will have indeed named and colored every
single point on the surface just once
with the exception of poles
every sequence has two poles of rotation
locations on the sphere that come back
to exactly where they started
for any sequence of right or left
rotations the poles are the north and
south poles the problem with poles like
these is that more than one sequence can
lead us to them they can be named more
than once and be colored in more than
one color for example if you follow some
other sequence to the north or south
pole any subsequent rights or lefts will
be equally valid names in order to deal
with this we're going to just count them
out of the normal scheme and color them
all yellow every sequence has two so
there are a countably infinite amount of
them
now with every point on the sphere given
just one name and just one of six colors
we are ready to take the entire sphere
apart
every point on the surface corresponds
to a unique line of points below it all
the way to the center point and we will
be dragging every points line along with
it the lone center point we will set
aside okay first we cut out and extract
all the yellow poles the green starting
points the orange up points
the blue down points and the red and
purple left and right points
that's the entire sphere
with just these pieces you could build
the whole thing
but take a look at the left piece it is
defined by being a piece composed of
every point accessed via a sequence
ending with a left rotation
if we rotate this piece right that's the
same as adding an r to every point's
name
but left and then right is a backtrack
they cancel each other out and look what
happens when we reduce them away
the set becomes the same as a set of all
points with names that end with l
but also u
d and every point reached with no
rotation that's the full set of starting
points we have turned less than a
quarter of the sphere into nearly three
quarters just by rotating it we added
nothing
it's like the hyper webster
if we add the right piece and the poles
of rotation in the center point well
we've got the entire sphere again but
with stuff left over
to make a second copy let's rotate the
up piece down the down ups cancel
because well it's the same as going
nowhere and we're left with a set of all
starting points the entire up piece the
right piece and the left piece
but there's a problem here
we don't need this extra set of starting
points we still haven't used the
original ones no worries let's just
start over we can just move everything
from the up piece that turns into a
starting point when rotated down that
means every point whose final rotation
is up let's put them in the down piece
of course after rotating points named uu
will just turn into points named u and
that would give us a copy here and here
so as it turns out we need to move all
points with any name that is just a
string of views we will put them in the
down piece and rotate the up piece down
which makes it congruent to the up right
and left pieces add in the down piece
along with some up and the starting
point piece and well we're almost done
the poles of rotation and center are
missing from this copy but no worries
there's a countably infinite number of
holes where the poles of rotation used
to be
which means there is some pull around
which we can rotate this sphere such
that every pole hole orbits around
without hitting another
well this is just a bunch of circles
with one point missing
we fill them each like we did earlier
and we do the same for the center point
imagine a circle that contains it inside
the sphere and just fill in from
infinity
and look what we've done
we have taken one sphere
and turned it into two identical spheres
without adding
anything
one plus one equals one
that took a while to go through but the
implications are huge and mathematicians
scientists and philosophers are still
debating them could such a process
happen in the real world
i mean it can happen mathematically and
math allows us to abstractly predict and
describe a lot of things in the real
world with amazing accuracy
does the monotarsky paradox take it too
far
is it a place where math and physics
separate
we still don't know
history is full of examples of
mathematical concepts developed in the
abstract that we
did not think would ever apply to the
real world for years decades centuries
until eventually science caught up and
realized they were totally applicable
and
useful the banach tarsky paradox could
actually happen in our real world the
only catch of course is that the five
pieces you cut your object into aren't
simple shapes they must be infinitely
complex and detailed
that's not possible to do in the real
world where measurements can only get so
small and there's only a finite amount
of time to do anything
but math says it's theoretically valid
and some scientists think it may be
physically valid too
there have been a number of papers
published suggesting a link between
banachtarski and the way tiny tiny
subatomic particles can collide at high
energies and turn into more particles
than we began with
[Music]
we are
finite creatures
our lives are small and can only
scientifically consider a small part of
reality
what's common for us is just a sliver of
what's available we can only see so much
of the electromagnetic spectrum we can
only delve so deep into extensions of
space
common sense applies to that which we
can access
but common sense is just that
common
if total sense is what we want we should
be prepared to accept that we shouldn't
call infinity weird or strange the
results we've arrived at by accepting it
are valid true within the system we use
to understand measure predict and order
the universe perhaps the system still
needs perfecting
but at the end of the day history
continues to show us that the universe
isn't strange
we are
and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
finally as always the description is
full of links to learn more there are
also a number of books linked down there
that really helped me wrap my mind kind
of around banach tarsky first of all
leonard wapner's the p and the sun this
book is fantastic and it's full of a lot
of the preliminaries needed to
understand the proof that comes later he
also talks a lot about the ramifications
of what bon aktarsky and their theorem
might mean for mathematics also if you
want to talk about math and whether it's
discovered or invented whether it really
truly will map onto the universe
yanofsky's
the outer limits of reason is great this
is the favorite book of mine that i've
read this entire year another good one
is e brian davies why beliefs matter
this is actually corn's favorite book as
you might be able to see there it's
delicious and full of lots of great
information about the limits of what we
can know
and what science is and what mathematics
is if you love infinity and math i
cannot more highly recommend matt
parker's things to make and do in the
fourth dimension he is hilarious and
this book is very very great at
explaining some pretty awesome things so
keep reading and if you're looking for
something to watch i hope you've already
watched kevin lieber's film on field day
i already did a documentary about
whittier alaska over there kevin's got a
great short film about putting things
out on the internet and having people
react to them there's a rumor that jake
roper might be doing something on field
day soon so check out mine check out
kevin's and subscribe to field day for
upcoming jake roper action yeah he's
actually in this room right now say hi
jake hi thanks for filming this by the
way um
guys i really appreciate who you all are
and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you